Virginia Woolf was a writer concerned
above all with capturing in words the
excitement pain beauty and horror of
what she termed the modern age born in
1882 she was conscious of herself as a
distinctively modernist writer at odds
with a raft of the staid and complacent
assumptions of 19th century English
literature she realized that a new era
marked by extraordinary developments in
urbanism technology warfare consumerism
and family life would need to be
captured by a different sort of writer
along with Joyce and Proust she was a
relentlessly creative writer in search
of new literary forms that could do
justice to the complexities of modern
consciousness her books and essays
retain a power to convey the thrill and
drama of living in the 20th century
Woolf was born in London her father was
a famous author and Mountaineer and her
mother a well-known model her family
hosted many of the most influential and
important members of Victorian literary
society Woolf was largely cynical about
these grand types accusing them of
pomposity and narrow mindedness Woolf
and her sister weren't even allowed to
go to Cambridge like their brothers but
had to steal an education from their
father's study
after her mother died when she was only
13 Wolfe had the first of a series of
mental breakdowns that were to plague
her for the rest of her life
partly caused to by the sexual abuse she
suffered at the hands of her half
brother George Duckworth despite her
illness she became a journalist and then
a novelist and a central figure in the
Bloomsbury group which included John
Maynard Keynes e/m Forster and Lytton
Strachey
she married one of the members the
writer and journalist Leonard Woolf she
and Leonard bought a small hand printing
press named it the Hogarth press and
published books from their dining room
they printed wolfs radical novels and
political essays when no one else would
and they produced the first full English
edition of Freud's works in just four
short years between World Wars 1 & 2
Woolf wrote four of her most famous
works
mrs. Dalloway to the lighthouse Orlando
and the essay a Room of One's Own in
March 1941 feeling the onset of another
bout of mental illness wolf drowned
herself in the river Meuse her work has
many vital things to teach us wolf is
one of the great observers of English
literature perhaps the finest short
piece of prose she ever wrote was the
essay the death of the moth published in
1942 it contains her observations as she
sits in her study watching a humble moth
trapped by a pane of glass rarely have
so many profound thoughts been eked out
from such an apparently minor situation
though for wolf there were no such
things as minor situations one could not
help watching him one was indeed
conscious of a queer feeling of pity for
him the possibilities of pleasure seemed
that morning so enormous and so various
their to have only a moths part in life
and a day moths at that appeared a hard
fate and his zest in enjoying his meager
opportunities to the full pathetic he
flew vigorously to one corner of his
compartment and after waiting there a
second flew across to the other what
remained for him but to fly to a third
corner and then to a fourth that was all
he could do in spite of the width of the
sky the far-off smoke of houses and the
romantic voice now and then of a steamer
out at sea wolf noticed everything that
you and ITIN to walk past the sky the
pain in other's eyes the games of
children the stoicism of wives the
pleasures of department stores the
interest of harbours and docks
Emerson one of her favorite writers may
have been speaking generally but he
captured everything that makes Woolf
special when he remarked in the work of
a writer of genius we rediscover our own
neglected thoughts in another great
essay on being ill Woolf lamented how
seldom writers stoop to describe illness
an oversight that seemed characteristic
of a snobbery against the everyday in
literature English which can express the
thoughts of Hamlet and the tragedy of
Lear has no words for the shiver and the
headache
the merest schoolgirl when she falls in
love has Shakespeare or Keats to speak
her mind for her but let a sufferer try
to describe a pain in his head to a
doctor and language at once runs dry
this would be her mission wolf tried
throughout her life to make sure
language would do a better job at
defining who we really are with all our
vulnerabilities confusions and bodily
sensations Woolf raised her sensitivity
to the highest art form she had the
confidence and seriousness to use what
happened to her the sensory details of
her own life as the basis for the
largest ideas wolf was always profound
but never afraid of what others called
trivial she was confident that the
ambitions of her mind to love beauty and
engage with big ideas were completely
compatible with an interest in shopping
cakes and hats subjects on which she
wrote with almost unique eloquence and
depth in another particularly good essay
of hers called the Oxford Street tied
she celebrates the gaudy vulgarity of
this huge London shopping street the
moralists point the finger of scorn at
Oxford Street it reflects they say the
levity the ostentation the haste and the
irresponsibility of our age yet perhaps
they are as much out in their scorn as
we should be if we asked of the lily
that it should be cast in bronze or of
the Daisy that it should have petals of
imperishable enamel the charm of modern
London is that it is not built to last
it is built to pass in an accompanying
essay equally open to the unprecedented
is--it the giant docks of London a
thousand ships with thousand cargoes are
being unladen every week and not only as
each package of this vast and varied
merchandise picked up and set down
accurately but each is weighed and
opened sampled and recorded and again
stitched up and laid in its place
without haste or waste or hurry or
confusion by a very few men in
shirtsleeves who working with the utmost
organisation in the common
interest are yet able to pause in their
work and say to the casual visitor would
you like to see what sort of thing we
sometimes find in sacks of cinnamon look
at this snake wolf was deeply aware that
men and women fit themselves into
Richard roles and as they do so overlook
their fuller personalities in her eyes
in order to grow we need to do some
gender bending we need to seek
experiences that blur what it means to
be a real man or a real woman wolf had a
few lesbian Affairs in her life and she
wrote a magnificently bold queer text
Orlando a portrait of her lover Vita
described as a nobleman who becomes a
woman
she wrote it is fatal to be a man or
woman pure and simple one must be woman
manly or man womanly in her anti-war
tract three guineas wolf argued that we
will only ever end war by rethinking the
habit of pitting of sex against sex all
this claiming of superiority and
imputing of inferiority belong to the
private school stage of human existence
where there are sides and it is
necessary for one side to beat another
side and of the utmost importance to
walk up to a platform and receive from
the hands of the headmaster a highly
ornamental pot wolf wished desperately
to raise the status of women in her
society she recognized that the problem
was largely down to money women didn't
have freedom especially freedom of the
Spirit because they didn't control their
own income women have always been poor
she cried not for 200 years merely but
from the beginning of time women have
had less intellectual freedom than the
sons of Athenian slaves women have not
had a dog's chance of writing poetry her
great feminist rallying cry a Room of
One's Own culminated in a specific
political demand in order to stand on
the same intellectual footing as men
women needed not only dignity but also
equal rights to education an income of
five hundred pounds a year and a Room of
One's Own
wolf was probably the best writer in the
English language for describing our
minds without the jargon of Clinical
Psychology the generation before hers
the Victorians wrote novels focused on
external details city scenes marriages
wills
wolf envisage a new form of expression
that would focus instead on how it feels
inside to know ourselves and other
people books like Wolf's which aren't
overly sarcastic aren't caught up in
adventure plots or cradled in convention
are a contract she's expecting us to
turn down the outside volume to try on
her perspective and to spend energy with
subtle sentences and in turn she offers
us the opportunity to notice the tremors
we normally miss and to better
appreciate moths our own headaches and
our fascinating and fluid sexualities if
you like this video then I think you'll
really appreciate wisecrack another fine
channel on YouTube that also celebrates
literature philosophy cinema psychology
and more click here to visit their
channel page and see how they're
introducing important topics and
critical analysis through the lens of
comedy if you're interested in smart yet
hilarious breakdowns of classic
literature be sure to watch their
popular series thug notes they have over
80 titles in their library to choose
from including Pride and Prejudice The
Great Gatsby Lolita June crime and
punishment and many more I think you'll
enjoy them as much as we do